I almost bailed on being a filmmaker the
thing that that kept me in the game was
the possibility of the Avatar Universe
reaching a lot of people with a
persistent message and reaction on part
of the audience to maybe fight for and
protect that which we're losing
[Music]
Titanic
[Music]
we talked about literally going to the
shipyard in Poland and building the
Titanic I said all right great so they
can build a Titanic for us for 10
million dollars yeah we should think
about that now if we sink it how many
takes do we get hmm one
you know what I mean it's like what if I
want a second take
so anyway we decided not to do not to
build the Titanic as an actual you know
floatable ship so then the question is
what do we build how do we break it down
what do we really need I had this idea
that look we've got this great
infrastructure just over the Border in
Mexico why can't we get the artists and
the crafts people and everybody and have
them ship up to Baja and do it right in
uh Ensenada just over the border that
way we can have American Crew or we can
get some English-speaking extras out of
San Diego and we can bring in thousands
of extras like we did from Mexico and
thousands of craftspeople and so on so
we decided to do that we built a studio
down there on a bluff overlooking the
ocean so that we could sort of see the
sea see see the Horizon have a kind of a
natural View and then we'd use obviously
digital Composites for other shots shoot
people in front of blue screen green
screen all that sort of thing
[Music]
I actually didn't see Kate At first she
had done a couple of other historical
dramas as well and she was getting a
reputation as corset Kate doing
historical stuff and so I thought oh man
this is gonna look like the laziest
casting in the world all right I'll meet
her sure you know but I was thinking
maybe Gwyneth Paltrow or somebody else
and I met Kate and she was fantastic she
was just fantastic and so that happened
fairly early on we found uh we found
Kate so Leo comes in I remember there
was a meeting with Leo and then there
was a screen test with Leo so the
meeting was funny because I'm sitting in
my conference room waiting to meet an
actor right and I look around and all
the women in the entire office are in
the meeting for some reason like there's
you know there's a female executive
producer okay fine but our accountant
you know why was she in the meeting they
just all wanted to meet Leo it was
hysterical I looked around and I went I
think I already know the answer to the
question here so Leo came in of course
Charmed everybody myself included
um and I said all right well let's see
what your chemistry is like with Kate so
he comes in a couple days later and I've
got the camera set up to to you know
record the video he didn't know he was
going to test he came in he thought it
was another meeting to meet Kate and I
said okay so we'll just go in the Next
Room and uh we'll just you know we'll
run some lines and I'll I'll video it
and he said you mean I'm reading
and I said yeah
he said oh I don't read I said well I
shook his hand I said well thanks for
coming by
he said wait wait wait you mean if I
don't read I don't get the part just
like that and I said oh yeah come on
this is like a giant movie it's going to
take two years of my life and you'll be
gone doing five other things while I'm
doing post-production and all the model
work and everything so I'm not going to
[ __ ] it up by making the wrong decision
and casting so you're going to read or
you're not going to get the part
oh
okay so he comes in and he's
you know he's like every
ounce of his entire being is just so
you know negative right up until I said
action and then he turned into Jack
and Kate just lit up and they went into
this whole thing and he played the scene
dark clouds had opened up on a ray of
sun came down and lit up Jack
I'm like all right he's the guy so then
I finally get the studio to agree to it
then Leonardo comes back in and he says
you know my dad and I have been talking
about the script and we really think it
needs this and this and this and this
and he wanted to have like I don't know
like some Affliction or some problem or
some traumatic thing from the past and I
said look you you've done all these
great characters that all have a problem
you know whether it's addiction or
whatever it is I said you got to learn
how to hold the center and not have all
that stuff this isn't Richard III when
you can do what you know Jimmy Stewart
did or or Gregory Peck did they just
[ __ ] stood there
they they didn't have a limp or a lisp
or whatever then you'll be ready for
this but I'm thinking you're not ready
because what I'm talking about is
actually much harder those things are
easier those are props those are
crutches what I'm talking about is much
harder and you're probably not quite
ready for it
the second I said that it clicked for
him that this was a really hard
challenging film for him and I realized
my mistake I hadn't laid out the
challenge for him sufficiently you want
the actor to love you you want them to
be in your movie you want them to say
yes so you make it all sound attractive
but he didn't want something that was
easy he wanted something that was hard
and that's been his Instinct since then
and it leads to things like the Revenant
right you don't get any harder than that
he knew how to map a career he just
didn't know specifically what to do in
that in that moment and but you see how
fragile this stuff is because you try to
imagine that movie without Leo or Kate
it's very hard to do
[Music]
choreograph the kiss in rehearsal weeks
ahead of time so we knew what we were
going to do even down to I drew little
lips on my hands here like this and I
showed them exactly you know who's going
to lead who's gonna press in who's gonna
end and add like a football play on lips
right and but they're both so analytical
they love that so we knew what we were
going to do the question is how were we
going to get the elements to agree we
scheduled actually for the first day of
our outdoor in case we had a nice Sunset
and it never looked good and we got down
so we burned through our whole 10-day or
two week window of our of our exteriors
and we were down to literally I think
the last day or the second to last day
and it was overcast and and I looked up
and I said we're going to get a sunset
tonight and probably 15 minutes before
Sunset it just opened up and turned into
these red bands and the sun came down
out of the overcast and it was like guys
we got a sunset so now everybody's
running running the length of the set to
get down to the bow and Kate had to like
whip one outfit off and get another
outfit on and she's sort of doing it in
the van and all her handlers around like
a like a Formula One pit crew I've never
had this happen with an actor in my life
before or since Kate gets up there she
takes one look at the sunset she turns
to me and screams shoot
actors are all they always welcome
you know to uh so anyway she's like
shoot
foreign
[Music]
we wound up getting two takes one take
was completely out of focus and the
other take was half out of focus and the
one that's half autofocus is in the
movie
The Terminator
I was in Rome and and I was sick I don't
know what with some some flu-like virus
and had a had a bit of a fever and just
had a dream and it was a an image that
you know that I remembered when I woke
up an image of a kind of chrome skeleton
emerging from a fire and I always
believe that dreams aren't just the
image there's also a kind of narrative
metadata that runs with it an image
where in the dream you know what the
image means in my dream I knew that all
of its outer covering had been burned
Away by the fire revealing it as a
chrome what what we later termed the
endoskeleton so then looking at it from
a from a purely practical kind of
strategic standpoint how could I as a
filmmaker try to break in and get a
directing gig Design This film so that
it was affordable enough that they would
trust it to me I knew I wanted to do
some visual effects but I didn't want to
set the whole thing on some some other
planet or some distant future so time
travel hey let's have him zap in to our
reality from some future reality okay
what are they trying to do you know
manipulate the past to change the future
that sort of thing so the pieces fell
into place around that seminal image
Arnold came in to talk to me about the
character of Rhys supposedly he had a
great deal of enthusiasm for the script
in general and when you know he was
waxing eloquent about the action scenes
but he kept talking about it kind of
from the terminator's perspective and
how cool that was and so on we didn't
talk about Rhys as much as I would have
expected somebody pitching themselves
for that character would have he just
had this kind of generic enthusiasm for
the for the film I couldn't get over
kind of how unique his face was how it
it just almost just projected this kind
of raw power and my conception of the
character had been that that he was more
of an infiltrator but then you know my
perspective shifted and I would say it
pivoted kind of on a dime all right if I
cast this guy how are they not all going
to see him coming how does he not stand
out in a crowd how do they not all look
at him and I thought you know what don't
worry about it because he would make an
amazing Terminator because I just saw
him as like this kind of bulldozer this
kind of armored tank you know and he
could just move through a crowd if
anybody was in his way he'd just pushed
him out of the way and you'd you'd
accept it it didn't even have anything
to do with the guns it was just that
kind of raw strength a kind of a machine
strength
Stan and I became great friends and you
know we hit it off right away I saw the
creativity that he had at his disposal
with his team he basically sculpted and
created the entire endoskeleton and all
the prosthetic makes up and the puppet
heads and so on and we tried to use
puppeteered heads for some of it and
then transitioned to prosthetic makeup
for other shots we didn't have CG in
those days today it's it's a no-brainer
how you do that it'd be very easy
actually but back then we had to you
know we had to be a little bit more
clever we had to figure out how we could
get a puppeteered head to match
perfectly with Arnold matching lighting
and matching you know camera angles and
moves and all that sort of thing
Terminator was done on really quite a
shoestring budget and Gail and I came
from that same kind of gorilla
background I was of that ethos that if
my hands weren't filthy by the end of
the day I wasn't directing a movie
you know because I was helping move the
lights help them move the camera help
him set everything up move the furniture
around that's just how I thought it was
I mean the culture shock didn't happen
for us on the first film it happened for
us on Aliens when we went to England and
they had a whole you know it was much
more of a kind of suit and tie thing and
the director kind of just sat back and
let everybody do their jobs and I think
that the English crew was unsettled to
say the least I think they were insulted
because they thought I believe they
didn't know their jobs and I had to help
them you know which wasn't it at all it
was just a sort of a muck in and get it
done kind of mentality plus they were by
the way slow as [ __ ] so you know I
thought maybe I could speed them up a
little bit
with Linda I felt strongly from from her
addition work that she could do both
pulls of the character she could do the
kind of you know valley girl just going
about her life kind of character but
with some make her interesting because
she had to be interested she had to not
be somebody that you would just dismiss
and then she had to have the strength
and the courage for the final scenes
you're a terminated [ __ ]
very fortunately she had that in Spades
in a way that was was never really
realized in the first film we didn't
really see it until Linda trained and
prepared herself for the second film and
then a whole new version of Sarah Connor
emerged and that's I think when she
became a a kind of feminist icon she
really flourished in the role and you
saw a whole other level not only of her
as an actor but kind of of Sarah as a as
a character as a planner as somebody who
is incredibly disciplined and focused
physically strong I've always joked that
Linda could just walk by a stack of
weights and she'd gained muscle even
when she trained lightly she'd get quite
buff but but she trained pretty
seriously for I want to say probably
five hours a day weights and movement
and weapons training and all that sort
of thing
foreign
[Music]
Terminator filmed it was six years later
when I wrote the script seven years
later and a lot of things had changed
for me I'd done much bigger stuff and a
lot of things had changed for Arnold he
was a big star so the business case was
a very different business case we knew
we could afford more I didn't set out to
make 100 million dollar movie I set out
to make a movie I thought it would be
maybe 50 million or something like that
I went back to an idea that I had had
for the original Terminator which is of
the liquid metal robot from the future
as well they're kind of their most
advanced being they send the guy back
that scares them that they didn't use
the first time because it was too
unpredictable they didn't know what was
going to happen if they turned this
thing loose and then I had to find the
right guy to play to play him Robert
Patrick obviously was it was a great
choice he really just inhabited that
role but of course the other thing was
we wanted to push the CG the liquid
metal surface the morphing so some fun
challenges and taking CG to the next
level a budget came out to somewhere in
the 80 Millions you know there's over 80
million and I thought holy crap but
that's what we went off at that's what
Carol called Green lit with a Big Gulp
and then as as production went on it
crept up and as it was you know kind of
approaching 100 million they were they
were blanching they thought they were
screwed and then it went out to be the
biggest hit of the year and so it all
paid off uh but it certainly felt like
gloom and doom at the time
Avatar
your blurry reflex is good
in a response normal how you feeling
Jake
hey guys Stan Winston and I form a
company called digital domain to create
CG World CG characters somewhere around
95 we founded it in 92 kind of came
online in 93. I wanted to write
something that I thought of as a as a
provocation something that I would go
get financing for and as a filmmaker I
could encourage slash kick everybody up
the backside to generate all this new
technology so I wrote Avatar which was a
kitchen sink approach it wasn't a smart
approach I just threw everything into it
that I thought would be cool and so we
sat we had technical meetings I talked
about I want to do facial performance
capture I want to do it with a camera
but they said we can't get there from
here we can't get to what you want to
create within a single movie cycle we
have to do other projects first and
build the tool set and work our way up
to it and by the way other people would
be doing it because the rising tide of
CG was lifting all the ships in the
entertainment industry at the same time
and people were developing new tools all
over the place so that was in 95 I got
it out and dusted it off in 2005. was
hitting a wall I wanted to make battle
angel I was three scripts in and I still
wasn't liking it and I thought well I
better have a backup plan here so I got
out of Avatar and I read it oh this is
pretty good you know this is actually
not a bad story so then we put battle
Angel and avatar on a parallel track to
develop the facial capture tools and we
thought maybe we flip a coin we'll do
one first and then the other and I was
thinking we'd probably do battle Angel
first that Avatar but then we got to the
eve of our big test and there wasn't a
scene written for the test and I thought
all right well I better write a scene
and so then I looked through the battle
Angel script and there wasn't a scene
that was CG character to CG character
and I thought well there's nothing I can
take from that well all right I'll look
in the Avatar treatment which was 80
pages long and there was a scene that
was pretty well fleshed out and it was
when Jake first meets natiri in the
forest and I said let's just do this the
decision was actually made without
realizing it that we were going to do
Avatar first because once we got into
that it just seem more and more obvious
that we needed to make that movie John
Lando my producing partner and I looked
at each other and said we're doing
Avatar
[Music]
we're not using photography we're using
performance capture so there there is no
world that I can show the actors other
than having them come over and look at
the Monitor and see the results of my
virtual camera pass and the interesting
thing is it turns out they're not that
interested they'll typically do it at
the beginning of a scene so they see the
setting okay it's a sunset there's a
waterfall over there there's some
creatures over here but they quickly
forget that or or it's not really
important what's important is the other
actor actors just need other actors
foreign
activist since since high school the
film wouldn't have existed if I hadn't
been because the head of 20th Century
Fox said I like the story it's a good
script can we get all this tree hugging
hippie [ __ ] out of it and I said I
actually know because the reason I want
to make the film is exactly because of
the tree hugging hippie hairy legged
Birkenstocks wearing you know [ __ ]
what happened after the film came out
indigenous leadership in various parts
of the world approached me and said your
film is showing the type of thing that
we're actually going through for real
and there was you know sort of the
unstated request was how can you help us
how can you help get our real story
out in front of people the way you the
way you did this fictional story so yeah
then then I went on a couple years of
actually becoming an overt activist and
trying to help them whether it was the
Athabasca tar Sands or down in Brazil
with the bellamanche dam and all that
and eventually I realized okay I can
just be another drive-by do-gooder or I
can go make more Avatar movies and reach
a much wider audience maybe with a
somewhat diluted message because it's
interwoven with entertainment but maybe
maybe throw a much broader net so that
was the point at which I decided to go
ahead and make more Avatar films which
was actually a difficult decision
because I had a lot of things I was
interested in in terms of ocean
conservation and sustainable agriculture
a lot of projects I was working on that
I had to turn away from to go back into
the saddle as a as a filmmaker I almost
bailed on being a filmmaker and the
thing that that kept me in the game was
the possibility of the Avatar Universe
reaching a lot of people with a
persistent kind of emotional message and
and reaction on the other part of the
audience to maybe fight for and protect
that which we're losing
foreign
I knew I was embarking on a multi-year
really a kind of decadal
project of course everybody was just
anxious for the sequel so it always
seemed like it was getting put off and
put off and put off it really never got
put off until we hit the pandemic and we
had to push out a year because we had
never really decided when we were going
to start we were going to start
production at the moment that we had
everything in a nice pile right so there
was technology there was design there
were the scripts it was a year and a
half to generate three scripts and then
six months for me to realize that the
first script needed to be two movies and
then 18 months for me to go back and
redraft and personally write all four of
the shooting scripts including the split
of the the first sequel so we started
production in literally five years ago
September of of 17. it's taken that five
years to to shoot all of Avatar 2 Avatar
3 part of Avatar 4 and then
post-production on Avatar 2 and parts of
Avatar 3. because parts of Avatar 3 are
actually already in work at what a
digital as we speak the new film is much
much more nuanced in terms of
performance much more complex
emotionally I think than the first film
by a country mile maybe an order of
magnitude the number of emotional scenes
Big close-ups that sort of thing that we
have in the new film is probably you
know five to ten times what we had in
the in the first film not to diminish
the first film the first film was more
about the awe and wonder this is more
about the characters
aliens
I had people who were trying to advise
me on my career after Terminator say
absolutely do not do this film meaning
aliens said if it's good they're going
to attribute it to Ridley and if it's
bad it's all you there's no upside and I
thought well you know you're probably
right and that's very logical but I just
dig it and I want to do it I just like
it the only variable for me was
Sigourney getting her into it because
they had assured me they had her on
under an option for a SQL option and so
I went off and wrote this thing okay I'm
gonna get to work with Sigourney this
will be cool I'll go off and write for
six months I come back lo and behold no
option they haven't even talked to her
so now it's up to me to land
Sigourney to talk her into doing this
film I don't know her from from you know
a stranger on the street
so I call her up and send her the script
and
she agrees to meet with me you know so I
went up there you know kind of
butterflies in the stomach because
everything I'd done in preparation for
this film she could shoot it all down
she it turns out had been really taken
by the story and so she was really
leaning in she wanted to do it and then
her agents got into it of course and
asked for the moon and then the studio
said absolutely no way and then the
whole thing fell apart again Gail and I
said okay [ __ ] all y'all we're we're
going to get married in Hawaii and it's
all off
and we just walked away and then they
went wait a minute did they just walk
away they can't do that
and uh so but you can this is just this
is just like movies how movies happen
and don't happen it's always it's you
know there's always a story behind the
story and so I called a blue pit
Arnold's agent and I said Lou we're kind
of over this right so we've decided that
we really like the story and all the
Marine Corps characters and the world
that we've created and everything and
really we've thought about it and we
really just don't need Sigourney I've
created all these characters and and my
pride of authorship tells me I should go
ahead with this and we'll just cut her
out of it and we'll just cut her
character out of it won't we won't
recast it I'll just rewrite it so I'm
going to start on that tonight now did I
have any intention of doing that
whatsoever no not at all but I happen to
know that Lou is at the same agency as
sigourney's agent who is in New York and
I knew that the second he hung up with
me he called him and said sign Sigourney
now and guess what the deal was done in
12 hours
after that so I never wrote A word of
that hypothetical story that I said I
was going to do that I had no intention
of writing anyway
so anyway it worked and Sigourney got
her million bucks and everybody was
happy
[Music]
get away from her You [ __ ] I'd actually
been writing this thing a couple years
earlier when I was still working for
Roger Corman called mother it was a
science fiction story and it ended in
this kind of Elemental battle between
the main character using a power suit
and this mother creature that was
defending her children so I wonder where
aliens came from it was basically just a
a revamp of that story so the the power
loader was innate already to that story
where I got the idea before that
exosuits had been in the literature the
Forever War they had these kind of power
suits that were kind of half spaced suit
half power suits Starship Troopers had
these kind of EXO frames that they used
to carry heavy loads it's like all the
stuff that DARPA has developed now for
actual use in infantry War fighting and
so if you think about it I went from
endoskeleton and Terminator to
exoskeleton and aliens
the abyss
well I always saw the deep ocean as kind
of Inner Space as having the same appeal
as outer space having that same kind of
remote Frontier dangerous not for the
faint of heart you know the Blackness
the fact that the sun doesn't reach
there you have to use high technology
and trust it to get down there and I had
written a a little story in in high
school called The Abyss after aliens
you know I thought well I'll just do the
abyss I'll just write a write a story
around that so but then I added in the
element of you know kind of an
extraterrestrial intelligence or a
non-terrestrial intelligence as I called
it in that and used it as a kind of a
first Contact story taking place instead
of an outer space in Inner Space in the
in the Deep more of a close encounter is
than it was a follow-on to aliens
um you know I didn't I didn't want too
much of the military stuff I didn't want
too much of that sort of conventional
action all movies are hard you know
they're long hours there's never enough
time you don't get enough sleep
everybody's working really hard and then
you add water to it and it becomes you
know well nigh impossible or
insurmountable but fortunately I happen
to like big challenges and I love being
underwater and I thought the idea of the
movie was really cool so you know
nothing was going to stop us so we had
to figure out you know helmets so the
actors could breathe underwater and the
lighting and all that and we basically
took underwater lighting from a very
primitive standpoint they were they were
lighting sets on the on the Deep with
500 watt lights so imagine you walk into
a set the size of a big Sound Stage and
your lighting kit consists of a 500 watt
bulb you're not going to make it through
the first day as a DP you're going to
get fired when you open your lighting
kit but that's what we that's all that
existed
so we went to some engineers and said
what can you do one engineer told us
you're all going to die you're all going
to get electrocuted the other engineers
said oh I know what to do we'll use that
we'll use HMI bulbs and we'll use double
inline ground fault Interrupters to make
sure that there's no short circuiting
that injures anybody and that's what we
did so we went with engineer B clearly a
guy named Pete Romano but
[Music]
okay that's okay
sweet Christ oh my God
[Music]
well I came up with this idea for this
Alien Probe that I called the pseudopod
and so the pseudopod was a water
tentacle it could lift itself off the
ground it obviously could sense its
environment it could image its
environment and so on I didn't know how
to achieve it I had the idea for it and
there were some non-cgi solutions that
we explored I talked to Dennis murin at
ilm he said have you thought about doing
it as as uh computer generated animation
and they were just getting into it
themselves and for me it was an unknown
terrain I didn't really drive this I
took the leap of faith based on Dennis
assuring me that it could be done now I
hadn't worked with Dennis before
but I knew him by reputation and he just
had this very calm very Zen demeanor and
he said they could do it and they did
and it took you know it took them a
probably a year and a half to do 16
shots now cut to 33 years later right
now we're doing
3 000 shots in two years on Avatar 2 the
rate of everything has accelerated the
pipelines have accelerated back then it
was very much pioneering work and hand
work by the animators